try a little bit different today after
we did the video on Dykstra I thought
well you know sometimes I like to go
home and sometimes do a bit of
programming in front of the TV you know
the person I am and one of the cool
things that you about being other
program is if you think all i wonder if
i could write something that would solve
mazes you can immediately go and
actually do that that thing so that's
what we're doing today I've come over a
bit of a part of a small program not
very complicated that fold mazes that
you give it an image for you get amazed
it worked his way through it and then
output say the same picture made from
red line on it is very exciting and but
I've also actually implemented lot of
different search approaches so I didn't
go into depth and breadth first search
and a star and Dykstra
want to see the actual code those things
then we'll make it available so other
people can follow along tweak it maybe
improve on what I've done it comes back
down to date well for the implementation
video doesn't it because there are so
many ways you can program something that
solves an image-based maze and how I've
done it is okay it probably isn't the
optimal I I had in mind i wanted to do
really big mazes in fifteen thousand
pixels by 15,000 pixel maybe bigger
about around now so I can't go any
bigger than that but so i'd love you to
be most semi efficient at the very least
you know not completely impractical and
so I thought to started by coming up
with some rules that my maid have to
follow because yeah okay so I could I
could give it any maze any picture made
a photograph of amazed but then most of
the time i'm going to be doing is now
just trying to turn that into a
structure in memory and that's what a
job right you want to be there I mean
yeah yeah and i'm just doing it in front
of the TV you know I get carried away so
what I said was I have a black and white
pixel image that hopefully doesn't have
jpeg compression on it because activex
everything is a blackboard all the way
around the outside that the wall and
then any black pixels wall anyway pixels
path and their intention to the top and
an expert at the bottom that that was my
boat my rules
I almost the other boot made it don't
follow the rules are going to work in
myself where you can follow me to extend
myself with how they're closed amazed if
you want I've got a very small image
here called tiny dot PNG which you can't
see because windows does not like to
expand these qualifies of images what
you don't do is give it the 50,000
50,000 image first go because if you
have any kind of problem you've no idea
what we want my baby started a small
image you can actually sort of debug
what's going on in the code you could
say well I was expecting this to happen
and it didn't which means i made a
mistake or something like this to start
with a small cases and then work your
way up to the bigger think hopefully
once you've got to add overbust album
that work for small limited on the mazes
just get a big amazing should figure
cross work first time we should think so
i've taught amazed right that took ages
to draw in video it but
you know just giving all this in a
little bit wayward here but you know
each of these square in a square and I
had enough nothing like that about it
than that
so my walls are that the outside is
black
apart from the top has one picture of
light which is the entrance and the
bottom have one picture of which is the
exit those are my rules that have come
up with now I said there are loads of
ways we could solve that maze
programmatically perhaps the first one I
did and it's so in the most obvious one
is just to put it into memory and then
kind of freak pixel look at the
neighbors and see if we can go there and
then move there and if maybe we can go a
bit further and so on so that with my
credit first trial implementation what I
did was like I copied it into memory or
storage array and then I say that's my
start position at not 123 naught but and
I said we'll look where can I go from
free not well well the left pixel to
know is is black the color there and the
next pixel across for North is black
longer there but this one isn't this 31
is white so i'll go there and I'll
continue my search from there and I
think the same for the blue car looked
at look left look like process and every
pixel like this is basically a flat
field but it's nothing smart about this
and it does work in the sense that it
will get into the end is loaded very
quickly you have to have a small but
says which nodes have been visited if
you otherwise you're just going to go up
and down up and down up and down up and
down it and get yourself into a loop or
here we got an actual loop we want to go
around and mailed if we don't have any
idea about where we've been so i created
another a variety of the exact same size
as this which was a true-or-false of a
foodie the right and just if you've been
visited you get that true and will ever
go back there but because by definition
we don't want to go backwards glue come
from
right but what if you get go to a
dentist partially so the data structure
that i'm using to do this breadth first
search is it's one that keep a bit about
our box to approach in our previous
video keeps retractable windows that
currently under consideration but
haven't been invented yet
so you know if it's been looking down
here have this one and maybe this one
maybe this one and when it gets to the
end here
we'll just go out and work out a little
fall back to this one so it highly
inherently allows itself to backtrack
and if I love doing it as you said that
as you sort of suggested which was I
just kind of followed blindly then i'm
going to be doing a lot of backtracking
now I had actually implemented version
of that was much aware that of life left
turn version as well good luck Hardaway
and implement a few different approaches
the problem with what i did here by
which is why i'm not showing the code of
this particular version is that it's a
beneficent like it's it's not massively
inefficient in memory because the right
don't take up a huge amount we even for
a really big image you know you know we
love these kind of images when we take
high-resolution photographs and things
so it's not inconceivable that you have
that amount of memory the issue more is
that over made of that kind of Sighs the
amount of nose under consideration start
to grow really quite rapidly that put
the memory and computational overhead
that we don't want and also if I'm
walking down this path here let's say
and I'm here like I can't let the right
here called left or right here
I called left to right here and I'm
spending a lot of time going to this one
adding it to the queue to this one and
then and going down here i'm taking one
two three four steps when we really want
that with a surprise now spit at people
interview at some point I'm going to
have to travel down there but I don't
want to store that information in memory
just seems a bit inefficient
so what i did was i wrote a a one-pass
which means one look over the image out
with them to turn this maze into a graph
like that one too dr. video i have no
idea is the optimal album for this
probably not but it was not going to
work and it extends quite reasonably two
large mazes as well let's have a quick
look at how that works let's go with our
green pen if we do one part of them what
we have to do is make all the decisions
we want to make by just cutting process
throughout medical office was and then
across thrown across the rope and you
could do it column wise but for the sake
of argument I've got that the most
obvious thing is once we get to the
start we can slide that the start and
that's good right so the first low we
simply move along until we get to start
and we create a node
in that position that my note little
have a little object in memory stored it
and it will store any of these
connections 20 neighbors but it can so
that's RS in the dark shades RS yes but
in in my implementation decision to
somewhere in the array this is an actual
tangible object in memory that has a
north east and west connection that
could have something connected to it in
this case is not gonna have a lot of
connection because you know not going to
go anywhere so for the next row i came
up with a number of rules that depending
on whether you're looking at war on the
flat part you do different things right
so the first one for example is if
you're on a wall
don't do anything but you can't right
now there you can't connect and he knows
to that point it doesn't make any sense
right so if you're on a wall but you do
nothing right and it's reflected in the
code if you're on a path and you were on
a wall that means you want to start
something new so we should create a node
but it start to get a little bit
confusing but I can basically I can't
with different rules so in this one we
talked their dad we can't go up we were
already on the path that we do nothing
this one we've got something about that
we can connect to
so we create a node here and we join
them up and we've just created a note so
we join them up like we know which is
literally created on the left so we're
tracking the ones above the ones to the
left and we're going this way down
always so microsoft way can I take a
break in motion TV and then I come back
the next day and and i'm going to ok so
now but this node this goes into
anything this doesn't do anything
because awful down to glow decision to
be made at this node is no point we make
anything in memory for here here this is
an obvious junction we can go down to
this point so we created those and we
connected back to the one we last saw on
the left and then again we get to this
one we're just in front of a wall at the
end of the corridor that's so exciting
we create a node and rejoined out by
this now there's a few statements
involved in that what you saw in your
line think about the steps you have to
take that each given position and what's
going on at that position doesn't take
very long to come up the steps you know
if there is a war on the left is all the
like is there a passel of those are the
things we basically have to check and
they will involve referencing the image
and saying is it was all that pixel
and the next one below by this one
doesn't left her life so it's a path
going downwards and don't do anything on
this one
alright this one the same this on the
side on the next row this one is a
junction so we created knows we
connected to the last one is all about
it which I stored in the list
incidentally for those of you following
along with my coach so we get to before
mrs. that this is the end of the
corridor we connect that in here we
start one here because that's the
beginning of a corridor end of the
corridor connect them up this one take
no action and you get the idea
over time we start to fill in wherever
there's an interesting junction anything
to be done
you see that this and we propagate this
through until eventually we finish off
our graph this unit I will actually
finish it off because i went to all the
trouble of doing out there we are
but now it's my algorithm is correct all
of these notes should exactly reflect
are made and what we've got it
insulated increase memory because these
loads a slightly bigger objects in the
underlying away which is just small
numbers but we have to take many fewer
steps to go across this late you know
the step counts from here to here is one
instead of 3 and so on and depending on
the length of your corridors in your
maze you can imagine that drastically
decrease the number of nodes you have to
be expanding into and so they want to
did was I said well okay so i put this
in the maze class so i go to class and
object in memory that stores this maze
have a start
it happened and then I started writing
other classes that their only task is to
go to later be so i did that first
search which expands all of them one
after another
remember next and the next and the flood
fill that first search with his fans as
far as to count one direction and then
the next election and so on and then
left her lonely which is where you with
her less and you get stopped all the
time and it with her left but it's a
closed famous made solving album because
if you're human and you can't see the
whole maze
it was quite well and then I also
implemented Dykstra in a style as well
so we'll see if it works
so that's one of the command prompt soap
in an ideal world I would have a name of
the file read in from a command line
parameters like I do actually have to do
that apartment was a bit lazy and I
hard-coded it so at the moment it was
tiny dot PNG could have told me to and
that's the only made it done so Python
so dot pie
there we are and so it creates the image
didn't take long with this is not a big
maze in fact it took no second to solve
made it only got 23 knows
let's see if that's true 123456789 10 12
14 efficient any more than 20 22 23 1
quite pleased actually because I could
have been really embarrassing but it's
that pile of debugging that I was doing
early on and getting funny amount of
nose and you think we're done wrong okay
i must have not connected these popular
something I've got a very technical
question for you what was entirely while
all this was going to wasn't le oh yeah
good point arm something like that to
cultural too hard it's got detailed plot
is difficult for me to also do this
community one thing that one
it took six 10,000 for a second i think
that is some fraction of a second to to
actually find the path explored lighting
know that means it looked at mind
impossible cabin nodes and eventually
found a path that would have length 94
here and if we look at the image which
again it difficult to do on this screen
so using the magic of editing this will
now appear very large and extremely
positive rather than that which has also
been linearly interpolated which is
exactly what I didn't want to happen on
this pc my previous video on linear
interpolation so I thought a pass in
from glutamate which represents the
start to the end
let's see if we can do something a
little bit more challenging like so here
i have a 2000 by 2000 image which when
you load up on my screen looks like a my
patent now i use the program with
Daedalus to generate this and you can
generate very large mazes I'm taking it
in some way on faith that there is a
bachelor star island could you know it
doesn't make a slightly different life
program so i had to go in and start the
end by partnumber why did on this one
and so on so let's see if it work
so this is called 2000rpm gee that's a
hard-coded change right on that and it
will take a little bit longer to
creative ways maybe
get coffee there we go light so it took
a second to create the maid and it had
760,000 node now when you consider that
amazing with two thousand pixels by 2000
pixels which is four million pixels and
let's say half of them white on average
then you would expect about 2,000 loads
if you were doing it the bad way
how about I try to save some money this
way it's essentially what i'm doing it
and then the actual the actual worm was
it that further breadth-first search
everyone i was breadth-first apparently
punch my code it takes 15 seconds not no
longer to get through that made and
again using wizardry I will resume in on
this and you can see it has found a path
through so it looks like a general
arcing path but if we zoom in you can
see it's actually finding its way from
quite complicated maze the last in class
is that the two major i just put in
that's open perfect mazes that means
there's only one possible solution
everything else is by definition a dead
end now somebody's are like that like if
you were to think of the Manhattan
Bridge systems amazed then in some ways
there's a lot of different parties could
take and really what you want to do is
find the shortest one tomato got here
has multiple solutions to it and so for
example if I want a depth-first search
on it it will be going down the first
part fine as far as possible and it may
well not take the shortest path because
it would just go down as part of our two
cans and that part might lead to the
exit it just might be very long so if i
change my algorithm to this image and
then get first right and we run it
okay he didn't take long 6300 knows a
hundredth of a second to actually
calculate it but it found all kinds of
super group through my mace and so calm
down here and then up here again and
back down here now the chances i
probably just jumped across here or
something silly
it just didn't occur to in some sense
because it was falling apart was on I
mean they're searching better associated
is two different problems like depending
on the northern knows you want to expand
but in this case suboptimal it would be
the site is not not the optimal
algorithm to use so I've also
implemented better search and a star and
Isis dices shortest path and so on if I
turn turn it into Dykstra has a bit of
overhead because you've got to set up
your quality q which i'm using Fibonacci
heat
do that because if not he also in the
code that reprogram yourself so if we
run this so the path length that debt
first found with a fountain world and
the parkland dr establish will be the
shortest path is 897 long they've been
taking a bit longer to do it just could
have many overhead mostly there we go
about the actual shortest path through
that maze which is significantly better
than the last one
yeah get download the code have a play
around see if you couldn't work out what
I've done and what I shouldn't have done
that maybe you can fix it and then come
up with a live album if you want to try
to work your way through to make and
depend on how much rather you have you
can see what kind of that size have made
it will handle and we look forward to
seeing some more pictures
yes but partner isn't as fast as doing
this in depth they see something like
that but it's not too bad and absolute
speed is not important for this because
i was just looking for fun and deceive
see you know with work right so you know
if you want to be implemented in a park
language is not the point arithmetic and
so on been you know go for it but